the Empire State Building the Sears
Tower the Canadian national tower each
of these structures was the tallest in
the world at the time they were built or
no errors so let's see they list a bunch
of structures here the Empire State
Building the Sears Tower the Canadian
national tower and then they talk about
each of these structures so really
they're talking about a singular subject
right over here each they said all of
these structures than we would talk
about we'll have we'd have a plural
subject but they're saying hey take one
of these at a time each of these
structures and so that make sense that
this is was because was would be the
singular form of the verb each of these
structures was if this was all of these
structures and we would put a word there
they'd say each of these structures was
the tallest in the world at the time
they were built now this is interesting
we started this is a singular subject
singular verb that makes sense but then
we shouldn't be referring today now
we're talking about each of the
structures so it was really at the time
it was built at the time it was built
remember we're talking about each of the
each of the structures taken
individually so each of these structures
was the tallest in the world at the time
it was built if you wanted to say they
were built you would have to say all of
these structures were the tallest in the
world at the time they were built but we
don't have the option of changing the
each to the all right over here so this
is since we're talking about a singular
subject we would keep the was and
instead of a they were it would be an it
was so let's just read the whole thing
over again
the Empire State Building the Sears
Tower the Canadian National Tower each
of these structures was the tallest in
the war it was the tallest in the world
at the time it was built
yep error in Part D